welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Witcher season 3 geralt Jennifer and
Siri are on the Run hiding from the
turmoil of the continent in this cute
little winter Airbnb and for a while it
is wonderful times as Papa G Mama yeners
and little CeCe get to live as a happy
found family but War Looms on the
horizon between the northern kingdoms
who want Siri for political reasons as
the heir to the kingdom of sintra and
the invading Empire of nilfgaard who we
learned at the end of last season the
emperor Amir the White Flame is Siri's
father the elves are currently aligned
with nilfgaard but they want Siri for
their own reasons because they think
she's their special prophecy kid that'll
lead them to the promised land and also
hunting Siri is the mysterious
Supernatural wild Hunt but they only
show up in one scene this season and
know more about them is explained but
the most immediate threat hunting series
is the fire Mage re-ents one day he
catches up to her but oh it was a trap
Carrollton yet if we're waiting for him
he has to retreat but now what's this
it's a double trap as the elves have
caught up to Siri too she would probably
help them if they ask nicely but instead
they're coming to kidnap her and
geralt's having none of that it turns
into one epic fight remember the the
leader of the elves is the Sorceress
Francesca but sexy Mohawk elf thinks he
knows better he's become good friends
with the nilfgaard guy kahir so they go
to see the emperor together like hey I
should lead the elves but kahir's in the
doghouse right now for lying to the
emperor at the end of last season so
it's like hey if you want my trust back
you gotta earn it he didn't like the
Mohawk Vibe and orders kahir to kill his
friend good job son I'm proud of you but
now kahir is feeling conflicted over in
the northern kingdom of rodania a main
character this season is the buffled guy
the spymaster Dykstra who's working with
the Sorceress Philippa the king is kind
of a doofus who's unconcerned with the
Brewing milfguard war in fact his Queen
thinks he should Ally with nilfgaard but
now nilfgaard sends his Queen's head in
a box yeah King I told you a nilfgaard
can't be trusted but turns out it was
dijkstra who killed the queen so he's a
shady guy meanwhile Philippa visits
geralt's best friend The Bard yaskier to
threaten him into given up Siri the
king's brother radovid wanted to tag
along and he takes a lighter touch hey
man I'm a huge fan and long story short
these two start flirting and yeah they
maybe fall in love now back to our
Witcher geralt who is occasionally still
on this show also occasionally a monster
shows up but it's Siri who takes Point
geralt's been training her and how to be
a Witcher and she's gotten real good
takes this thing out herself she also
has magic and Jennifer's been teaching
her how to use it so Siri's becoming
quite the PowerHouse so geralt is
hunting that fire Mage re-ends but in
his lair he's been doing experiments on
young women oh sewed their bodies
together Elden ring style he manages to
save one what's your name kid but she
thinks she is Siri her mind's been
Enchanted this kind of magic is too
powerful for riance he must be working
with a stronger sorcerer and not just
his boss with the messed up face she's
just the go-between for someone real
strong in the Brotherhood yes the
Brotherhood of sorcerers for a long time
has been dominated by old douchebags
like stragabor but the good guy
vilgavortz is trying to make things
better along with Jennifer's Mama Bear
to Saya and remember these two are in
love so Jennifer comes back to the
Brotherhood and convinces them to throw
an epic party in the name of Northern
Unity but it's just a cover for her and
geralt to uncover the real villain and
they're pretty sure it's stragivore they
get some help from their friends Tris
Marigold and distraid she figured out
the missing apprentices were all half
Elven and he's hunting down a book on
monoliths that someone stole from the
Restricted Section remember istrid was
Jennifer's College boyfriend and so
geralt picks a fight with him that
distracts stragabor and lets Jennifer
sneak into his room she finds some
evidence of the missing girls and istrid
finds the monolith book so jigs up
Dragonborn we got to red-handed
strikerboard confesses to being a racist
old bastard who hates elves and thinks
that the mudbloods should be banned from
Hogwarts so after the party geralt and
Yen taking a bath like wow that was easy
was it too easy and the episode goes
back to show the party from a few
different angles where everyone has some
secret agenda in the end their clue is
to say a seashell bracelet that vilga
forts gave her yeah nice guy Phil
gaforts is the big bad but before geralt
can kill him dextra is one step ahead he
and Philippa captured All The Hungover
Sorcerers because they knew vilgavortz
was working for nilfgaard so they're
doing a Brotherhood coup but they missed
to Saya who's a real powerful Mage and
breaks all her friends out of handcuffs
and the Mages did not appreciate this
rude awakening but now vilgaforch
reveals he is the villain and he doesn't
love to say uh he was playing her this
whole time so they break up and now it's
time for coup round two as he lets in a
bunch of nilf guard elves but the
brotherhood's ready to defend their home
and so it's a big Harry Potter Battle
Santa tries to kill their leader
Francesca but her boyfriend jumps in
front of it ow Philip Andrew now
Francesca's real mad so she tears down
their big chandelier then to say it goes
for a real big spell Force lightning pew
pew pew but in the end a bunch of the
elves are still standing so who's this
busted in it's old man's Dragonborn
killing elves now this is a party and he
saves the day with the power of racism
our main characters were not here for
any of this excitement riance caught up
to Siri again so yennefer throws the
sword for an alley-oop oh but now kahir
finds Siri too and he's the one who led
the attack on her hometown sintra so
she's real mad goes to kill him but he
immediately surrenders yeah he's kind of
realized that maybe nilfgaard's the bad
guys and I feel real bad for hurting you
Siri so I pledge myself to you so
serious confused and lets him run away
meanwhile istrid found the monolith book
but bilgefort caught up to him and
bamped him back to his secret lair and
now vilgaforch is coming for Siri but
geralt's here to protect her and so
what's the fight
has the magic staff that can teleport to
either hand now vilgaforce was thought
to be like a mid-tier sorcerer but now
he reveals he's been hiding his true
power all along oh he's like one of the
strongest Sorcerers ever with his magic
staff he breaks geralt's sword and then
breaks geralt's back and leaves him
alive as a warning meanwhile Siri has
wandered over to the magic Tower which
turns out inside is a big monolith but
this one's got like writing on it
vilgaforce is like Siri I want to help
you learn to use your powers but she's
like I figured it out enough and blows
them both up Siri is teleported to the
middle of a desert and if you like
hour-long episodes of wandering the
desert you're in luck she hallucinates
her grandma being mean to her then
hallucinates a mysterious robed woman
who turns out is kind of real she is
Siri's ancient ancestor falca who is
like part elf and cursed the whole world
and wants Siri to bring about the
apocalypse her reasoning is if the
current world order is evil then
destroying the world is the good thing
to do so she's trying to push Siri to
the dark side and it sounds pretty nice
having the power to destroy your enemies
but Siri has the vision that she would
end up killing her friends too and she's
like oh no I reject it when she wakes up
she's found by bounty hunters but at
least she's out of the desert not to say
is very depressed and she kills herself
no mama bear so Jennifer gathers what's
left of the Brotherhood but it's
basically just her class of sorceresses
well then girls it's time for a Rebrand
I guess we'll be the sis Hood now by the
way the nilfgaard Sorceress frangila is
back remember last season when someone
killed the elf baby and fragile took
credit to gain favor with the emperor
but it was Amir himself who had the baby
killed so he knew she was lying and
punished her they pinned it on the
northern kingdom so the elves would
fight for an elf guard but now frangela
tells her the truth and Francesca is
gonna be real mad at nilfgaard over in
rodania deekster is in trouble because
his Brotherhood coup failed the king
orders him to kill Filipa but he loves
her you could kill me instead she's like
oh boo that's sweet but unnecessary I've
already made plans to have the King
assassinated and she immediately crowns
his brother radovid who hopefully she
and dextra can manipulate better now
back to our Witcher geralt of Rivia who
is occasionally still on this show his
dryad friends are trying to heal him but
he keeps running off to try to rescue
Siri he makes a new friend milva who
convinces him he's in no shape to fight
and agrees to help train him to get back
into shape and after a little training
montage yeah geralt is back in fighting
form now word on the street is that
nilfgaard finally captured Siri but oh
it's the Imposter Siri it seems like
vilgafortz is trying to trick the
emperor and yeah by the way his face is
now super scarred after the Obelisk
explosion but he must not know that Amir
a series father and immediately
recognizes this ain't his daughter the
real Siri is still captured by bounty
hunters and she makes friends with her
other captive because his friends are
coming to rescue him yes apparently
they're a gank called the rats and there
are a bunch of fun Misfits who are top
tier Fighters their leader gives Siri an
audition to join him and yeah she makes
short work of this guy but she's only
ever killed monsters before this was her
first human murder and when they're like
yo girl what's your name she gives her
evil ancestors name call me falca but
Daryl thinks she's still a nilfgaard and
when crossing the border the guards
harassed his family and geralt's gone on
his character Arc I can't be neutral
anymore I have to stand up for good so
geralt fights a dozen guards yeah he's
basically fully healed his new friend
milba's here to help too she's gonna
join on this adventure for her own
reasons and yaskir is still here uh he
helps a bit too and so are Witcher
geralt of Rivia adventurous forth to
rescue Siri although apparently Henry
Cavill is leaving the show so next time
you see him he'll look different and
that's where the Witcher season 3 comes
to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]